als ich heute morgen hörte dass 40
prozent davon hatte ich nicht richtig
gefreut okay weil die deutschen müssen
langsam an also nur ein bisschen schlaf
wir machen den kinderwelten der rest was
die amerikaner die drecksarbeit in der
verteidigung in der sicherheit und in
all diesen bereichen sie müssen langsam
mal wach werden dass die realität nicht
darin besteht dass das supermodel des
konsums und des tvo lebens so schön so
der polizei kein gesicht ganz klar
übrigens ist nicht das erste land
bulgarien den baltischen staaten hatte
er auch runtergefahren haben die anderes
vorgesorgt aus meiner sicht sie wird
aber jetzt sagen sie mir die saison ist
gesichert sie ist jetzt gesichert wir
haben in diesem zeitpunkt in diesem
moment die geringsten gas verbraucht den
jahresverlauf wir haben also eine high
life situation lassen sie erst mal
kommen die haben sich vorgenommen dass
die kann dass die reserven die übrigens
auch unter kontrolle russische
unternehmen liegen die wir jetzt mit
weiterfinanzieren mit einem jahr und 10
milliarden die gasspeicher dass die bis
90 prozent gefüllt sein werden das sind
immer davon ausgegangen dass angela di
mi do kann war mir in rom hatte laut
erhardt und seine freundin angela
weiterhin dieses wunderbaren den stoff
aus dem die träume sind liefert er aber
nicht und dann wird es ein bisschen kalt
werden und ich garantiere ihnen wir
werden die atomkraft mit handkuss wieder
begrüßen und wir werden die
kohlekraftwerke weiter haben weil sie
vernünftig sind und wir werden auch die
gaskraftwerke weile haben weil sich
vernünftig sind und wir werden deswegen
nicht frieren weil in der hoffentlich in
der politik setzt sich sehr auf ihre
partei dass die in diesen tagen die fdp
ist man
einer energiewende rückwärts bei angela
ja das ist meine hoffnung und deswegen
danke ich mich dass uns die russen
zeigen wo hier an hannes den most holt
aber der ist reaktivierung jetzt die
völlig falsche dafür glaube ich für ihn
wie für rückhalt sowieso na ja ich gehe
also ich glaube halt nicht dass sie alle
ihren positionen verraten also die
normal des faktischen
straßendemonstrationen werden die wahl
das hat möglicherweise eben gar nicht
politisch sozusagen in dem parlament
fliegen sondern werden werden bedeutet
krieg wenn sie das erste mal ihre
rechnungen nicht mehr bezahlen wenn es
wenn es stromausfall ist wenn wir den
ersten blick auf mal haben weil unsere
ganze energie versorgung zusammenbricht
dann bin ich sehr gespannt wie viele
leute immer noch auf die atomkraft
verzichten wollen oder ob er dann
endlich mal darüber reden dass
deutschland mal in die lage versetzt
wird sich alleine energiepolitisch
überhaupt zu ernähren durch ja wir sind
ja wir haben ja das glück dass wir
sozusagen gemeinden noch freundliche
nachbarn haben wir sind von freundlichen
nachbarn umgeben uns freundlicherweise
diese energie auch den strom liefern den
wir selber nicht mehr produzieren weil
wir ja sagen wir machen atomfreie und
wenn die russen nehmen wir auch noch den
hahn zudrehen dann wird es dann wirklich
sehr ungemütlich werden und spätestens
im herbst wenn die energiewende auch der
energiebedarf steigen wird und dann wird
das gar nicht der die fdp brauchen weil
dann wenn die leute auf der straße
nämlich sehr unruhig werden und dann
wird der druck auch auf eine rot-grüne
regierung deutlich größer werden weil
dann kann herr haben uns erklären warum
wir frieren sollen die hörer glück durch
schon also die erwartet ja die fdp
braucht ist was ich erst seine fdp
brachte ist das immer aber was sich an
der these ganz spannend finde wir müssen
ja was politisches davon auch ableiten
und ich glaube das muss uns mal zu der
diskussion führen wir haben es mit
russland erlebt wie verhalten wir uns
zum beispiel auch gegenüber der
volksrepublik china geben wir uns da
wieder in wirtschaftlicher
abhängigkeiten machen wir das gleiche
modell was wir jetzt sozusagen auch mit
den russen ja jetzt auch gerade
vorgelesen bekommen durch handel herber
schlag ich glaube dass wir auf alle
fälle lernen müssen dass wir für unsere
werte robust auch im zweifel einstellen
und das ist glaube ich eine position als
ein hartes warum genau es geht darum
dass wir nicht erpressbar sind und
deswegen ist zum beispiel mein blick
schon eher richtung china also wir
werden aus russland jetzt einrichtung
volksrepublik müssen und da muss auch
europa zusammen stehen also warum
erkennen wir zum beispiel nicht endlich
die republik taiwan an sagen das ist ein
verbündeter für uns im asiatischen raum
und arbeiten dann sozusagen auch daran
wie wir uns wirtschaftlich unabhängig
von china machen können also das machen
ja nicht mal die amerikaner naja lassen
sie uns doch mal mutig sein den tag
warte ich dann die kröten wahnsinnige
projekte zu zahlen
das system ist gar keine frage und die
russland auch ganz klar und nun wir
haben uns abgewöhnt zwischen freiheit
und unfreiheit zu unterscheiden wird
durch den völlig prinzipienlos von sind
nur jedes wissen nur mit arroganz und
überheblichkeit
ich kann ihnen sagen es wird ganz bitter
werden aber ich setze auf die normative
kraft des faktischen und was ich
vermisse ist eine würdige ehrliche
diskussion die wird nicht kommen der ära
merkel es tut mir leid es sind hier am
tisch vertreter der unionsparteien sie
die fdp ich bin noch still leiden
die erde war ja
für dieses land eine heimsuchung und
zwar in mehreren
mehreren kapiteln wir fragen der einmal
verlängert sie ist davon erzählte sie
habe das interview von frau merkel
gesehen wo sie jetzt alle meine stimme
geben hat gehört haben ist fanden sie
sie da selbstkritisch haben sie als
selbstkritische bickeböller kanzlerin
wahrgenommen oder glauben sie dass die
union schon auch in sich drin jetzt
hadert mit der zurückliegenden ergie
wände
selbst kritisch so richtig habe ich sie
nicht liebt weil sie ja doch auch so ein
bisschen versucht hat so erklären
bisschen mehr wie sonst auch glaube ich
getan hat
ja es ist also im verhältnis zu putin
also ich sag mal ganz ich hab sowieso
meine eigene these wenn ich ganz ehrlich
bin was ist ihre sache aber das ist
sicher nicht allgemeiner union sprechen
angespornt ich persönlich glaube ich
sage ihnen ganz ehrlich dass sie putin
mit noch dream 2 den den krieg abgekauft
hat sozusagen das sie in richtig
eingeschätzt hat politisch meiner man
sie die anderen zwei klug war nein nein
nein aber sie hat ihn sozusagen ruhig
gehalten um in weltkrieg schon früher zu
verhindern indem sie in das ist so
typisch so habe ich die auch erlebt
probleme abroll mit dem man was gibt ja
an sich
gilt ein gefühl von mir so wie ich es
empfinden das ist nicht unions haltung
gesagt auch keiner das ist nur so so wie
ich sie erlebt habe und viele probleme
ich sage mal energiewende also ich zb
mal konnte das machen was war und damals
umstritten ich war sogar so dass ich
dachte vielleicht ist es auch eine
chance weltweit mal wieder in einem
neuen bereich auch weltmarktführer zu
sein über die ersten sind also ich habe
da durchaus positiv gedacht aber dann
wurde halt gross entschieden das
politische thema abgeräumt und dann aber
nicht alle kraft darauf gesetzt um das
zu lösen ist auch das was ich am meisten
vor beginn ihrer regentschaft dass sie
wenn ich so einen mega entscheidung
treffe nicht mit von kraft mit den
besten leuten da reingeht dass sich das
thema dann auch wirklich in zehn
fünfzehn jahren gelöst habe das ist doch
dass wenn ich so ein mega projekt mache
wie
unabhängige tische erneuerbaren energien
setze und das ist das wo ich bei ihr
mehrfach erlebt habt thema abräumen
schieben aber wird schon hoffentlich gut
gehen und und so ist es ja immer also
deshalb wirkliches gefühl dass sie putin
richtig eingeschätzt hat werden wir sehr
gute menschenkenntnis
auch politisch unglaublich erfahren und
in still gehalten hat und gehofft hat
dass ich das vielleicht alleininhaber
dann ist es noch besser sogar zu frage
glauben sie dass wenn frau merkel
geblieben wäre als kanzlerin der krieg
nicht ausgebrochen wäre
ich das kann ich auch nicht so sagen
also ich glaube er hat ein momentum
genutzt wo er dachte das ist der
optimale termin schwachen olaf scholz
wäre es jetzt ja wir haben ukrainische
einem aus seiner sicht vielleicht
schwachen ganz falsch eingeschätzt das
mediale kompetenzen der heutigen welt
starke
persönlichkeit entführer sein können die
er dachte diesen schwach er hat gedacht
jetzt ist regierungswechsel ist nicht
die die ihn schon lange kennt und und
ihre netzwerke die hat ja natürlich
netzwerke weltweit hat dann aber wusste
ja dass die damit drohen jetzt alles
auszusteigen erneuerbare energien also
die neue ampel regierung am sehr groß
verkündet north stream 2 und ich glaube
sagt komm jetzt zeige ich euch mal wie
abhängig ihr seid war da man sehen wir
bei dir her kommt mit eurem
überheblichen wir schaffen das alles
einfach gelöst sein konnte also das
heißt er hat aus seiner sicht meiner
einschätzung nach ich bin kein
jurist perfekte moment für seinen plan
es ist nicht so aufgegangen wie er sich
das vorgestellt hat
er war doch selbst überrascht wie
überrascht dass die europäer glaube ich
alle so außerdem ein geheimnis ist
verteidigt dass die ukraine ich glaube
aberglaube dass ich glaube dass wir von
glück reden können dass wir im moment
nicht mehr von merkel regiert werden
weil dann hätten wir nämlich diese
einigkeit nicht und wer hätte der
krisenpolitik der ukraine gegenüber wir
hätten genau dieselbe situation wie
damals als als die krim annektiert wurde
und man ihn hat gewähren lassen es war
doch eine frau merkel mit ihrer
regierung die die die zugelassen hat
dass die russen sich die creme genommen
hätten und sie hätten jetzt genauso
reagiert und genau damit hat immer
wieder gerne würde ich sagen sie können
von glück reden dass wir gerade von der
ampel regiert werden weil natürlich auch
realpolitisch jetzt eine rot-grüne
regierung genau das machen würde was sie
bekämpfen würde wäre merkel und die cdu
immer noch in der regierung dann hätten
wir nämlich die friedensbewegung auf der
straße und jetzt muss eine frau baerbock
tor unter reichen und muss den leuten
erklären warum wir nicht helfen sollte
man sie nicht weil sie realpolitisch
sieht das ist nötig und das war damals
schon die ruhige
dieselbe situation und wir können
wirklich von glück reden dass angela
merkel nicht mehr im amt aber das ist
doch auch die frage wie wir da endlich
mal außenpolitisch auch in den umgang
treten also wir haben es ja sowohl in
der europäische wenn ich mir anschaue
die diskussion zu polen die um
diskussion zu ungarn die haltung erdogan
also brauchen eine gewisse robustheit
und ein gewisses ein eintreten draußen
und ohne die schaffen das nicht
[Gelächter]
angenehm sein
charme den sie auch schwangere frau ich
finde es abenteuerlich wie sie eine
bundeskanzlerin gut sein dass sie in die
zukunft hinein mutmaßt dass herr putin
musste nur lesen was darüber gegeben hat
vielleicht auf ihre gesten reagiert
sagen sie mal eine bundeskanzlerin muss
strategischen ausblick haben sie muss
alle dinge ganz klar beherrschen die
einem menschenalter ich will das gar
nicht weiter ausführen das für großen
ärger bedeuten aber wie kann man denn
beim hausbau beginnen indem man das dach
zuerst macht und nicht das fundament der
liga und herrn energie flach und haben
keine möglichkeiten von nord nach süd
drin energie energie transportieren wenn
das nicht ein stück aus dem tollhaus ist
von einer frau die glaubt physikerin zu
sein was sie wohl auch ist und sagt sie
dieser sieht sie nicht bloß ein wieder
das bewährte die
abschlussrede über in der abschlüsse das
ist ein thema für sich so punkt und das
bedeutet natürlich ich bin sehr klar
meiner einschätzung glauben sie man das
hat eine menge kenntnis was das betrifft
diesen bereich deutschlands also die
frau hat ganz klar gehandelt und musste
sehen welche folgen diese politik hat
und dies muss die deutsche geschichte in
der forschung eines tages aufklären
heute macht man das nicht weil die
cdu/csu eine befolgt same
gleichgeschaltete truppe ist ich wünsche
friedrich merz den ich gut kenne alle
kraft stück für stück die alte union
nicht mit mir nicht die modernität aber
wer die offene diskussion in union
herzustellen frau merkel und ich merke
aber
dass merkel nicht so oft dass sie
gedacht und gefühlt hat und gemeinsam